foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
the dude who bought Twitter
foreign
s for eight bucks
he literally is like I'll take your
spare change please please please don't
leave
please don't leave the platform that I
just bought that I'm gonna crash into
the ground
I don't know why no one saw this coming
if if Elon bought Twitter that he would
drive it absolutely into the ground
I don't know if he's mad that he was
forced to buy it because he really
didn't want to he he didn't want to pay
a fine he was trying to get out of any
way he could and now he's just gonna
crash it
but he is literally in the replies of
Stephen King begging him for spare
change
begging him for eight bucks a month
because the the word is is that they're
going to charge verified accounts 20
bucks a month to keep their blue chick
not not only is there not enough
verified accounts for this to be a point
of Revenue
when the verified accounts leave you
won't have traffic to I don't know make
Revenue off of this is really [ __ ]
dumb this only proves how stupid Elon
Musk truly is how [ __ ] dumb Elon Musk
is I'm this is not a joke this is real
yesterday Stephen King tweet and I'm
gonna I'll probably show it to you Texas
Paul is going to join us today so
depending on how long Texas ball talked
but here's the thing Elon Musk yesterday
and well I think a day before announced
that he's going to charge 20 bucks for
verified blue checks right I don't know
if he has to throw in his own 20 a year
or not I don't know as the owner I'm not
really sure but here's the thing is that
Stephen King yesterday the author
Stephen King said I'm not gonna pay 20
bucks you can go [ __ ] yourself
you're gonna try to make 20 bucks off of
me because I'm me Elon you're a dumb
[ __ ]
listen
everyone wants to know
why this is a distraction it's a
distraction because there is the most
important election of our lifetime
so it's funny that Elon Musk is begging
for Stephen King's spare change like
he's you know some kind of
beggar on the street
you know with his hat handed out
which is really which is really up
elon's alley anyways he's always taking
other people's money
to try to make money we we know that
he's a [ __ ] government subsidy [ __ ]
but here's the thing
we need not need to be distracted by
this and do not leave Twitter yet
I mean I I know you're gonna leave it
eventually it's gonna be a [ __ ] trash
Heap
just in a week in a week Elon Musk has
made it questionable rather Twitter can
be profitable even he is questioning it
even he is questioning currently as we
speak rather the company he just bought
which was profitable last week
is going to be profitable in the future
the only difference is he bought it
whoosh
and he overpaid for it which I'm excited
about that's right I'm excited that Elon
Musk overpaid for Twitter
but the point of me telling you this is
to not leave yet don't leave yet
we got just a few more days left to yell
and scream
and we have to yell and scream we've got
to combat these morons no matter how
much they try to [ __ ] suppress it or
whatever whatever they're trying to do
you know I'm not really sure I think
they they've fired
um a lot of employees or locked them out
of the moderation tools to be moderators
on Twitter
so that they can't moderate certain
misinformation because they really want
to disseminate misinformation at this
point I mean Elon Musk has proven that
this is all a ploy for you to dump
Twitter
it's what it is
it's a ploy he's gonna he's gonna crash
this thing into the ground that's his
goal
either that or he's a dumb [ __ ]
either way not good not good situation
but listen we have the most important
day that is going to come very soon it's
next week one week from today
it is super important that you not give
up at this point
that you don't go in search of a social
media platform that's not going to get
your voice out
and I know it's difficult times getting
your voice out but do it any way you can
it doesn't have to be on Twitter either
if you have a following on Instagram on
Facebook but the most important thing
here folks the most important thing that
you can do
to combat Elon Musk and all the [ __ ]
misinformation and all the [ __ ] is
to do what I've been telling you
find and encourage three people
three people to vote if you have already
found your three people encouraged and
encouraged them to vote and they're
currently finding three more three
people themselves find three more to
encourage
I don't know if you looked at the early
voting numbers but they're astounding
it's even shocking to me and I'm very
confident I'm very optimistic about our
chances here
I believe this defeatism is all [ __ ]
bred from the right wing it's all
Republican misinformation that's being
fed to the media and they're believing
it hook line Sinker folks there is more
early voting now than ever in a midterm
history
and the facts are showing that yeah it's
not it's not Republicans or the voting
because they don't believe in voting
anymore
Charlie Kirk said yesterday that we're
not a democracy
he is telling listen to me listen to me
when I tell you this I'll slow down if I
have to Charlie Kirk is telling his
supporters that we in this country are
not a democracy
they're suppressing their own vote folks
this this talk from the right
is twofold that we're not a democracy
one they don't want you to vote one two
when they take away your democracy they
want you to believe you didn't have it
in the first place
because how can you steal something from
someone that they didn't know they had
but it's up to you it's up to you so
don't leave Twitter
be pro-democracy [ __ ] them you know what
you should do lean into it really lean
into Twitter I mean are they gonna
silence you now for saying what you want
to say I mean they're not going to
silence anybody else so lean into that
[ __ ]
scored stirth on these pieces of [ __ ]
it's enough of this garbage this fascist
garbage and they want to silence us
they're trying to silence me
currently a right-wing troll Farm trying
to silence me I won't be silenced I will
not shut up I know they're terrified of
what I say but more than anything
they're terrified that you listen to
what I have to say and that scares them
they're terrified
they're terrified that you go to a place
every single weekday for two full hours
for me to absolutely bash them up
bash up their beliefs bash up their
fascist ideology
in a cathartic way that you can take out
into the world and spread to three
people and encourage them to vote
they're [ __ ] terrified of that
it ain't got nothing to do about what I
did or what I'm doing now or it ain't
got nothing to do with that [ __ ]
they're terrified of you
they're scared of you
and the reason why is because you're
[ __ ] voting
you're [ __ ] voting like your
democracy's life depends on it because
it does
and they're not going to get me to shut
the [ __ ] up
how could they have you ever have you
they obviously haven't been here at the
Tony Michaels podcast long enough to
know that they're not going to get me to
shut the [ __ ] up
so we cannot be distracted
by elon's doing this or elon's doing
that with Twitter lean into it [ __ ] him
[ __ ] them go reopen your Facebook
account and just start pounding the
airwaves talk to your people that are
around you
ask them what the most important issue
is to them right now in this moment
and when they say something like I don't
know gas prices talk to them
talk to don't bury them in facts don't
[ __ ] give them a bunch of Statistics
they are not going to give a [ __ ] about
that they're not
they they just are not going to give a
[ __ ] about that
they're gonna care about our democracy
because folks you're that if we give
this democracy to fascists and they tear
it down and we do not have democracy
anymore you are not going to have to
worry about [ __ ] the the least of
your worries is going to be gas prices
and milk you'll be lucky to get gas and
milk in the first place
when a bunch of dumb [ __ ] right
Wingers take over something you see what
happens look at what happened is
happening to Twitter right now it's been
less than a week and the [ __ ]
begging Stephen King for spare change
begging him in his replies for spirit
that person who owns Twitter is begging
Stephen King for spare change
in the replies that's how well they do
when they take over [ __ ] and they
[ __ ] control [ __ ]
that's how well they do
so you're gonna give [ __ ] like
that you're gonna give them the reins of
our economy the reins of policy to
dictate what happens in our economy
you're gonna trust them with gas and
grocery prices you are a dumb
[ __ ]
if you're gonna trust people like Elon
Musk and his [ __ ] incel army with our
[ __ ] economy
he can't even figure out that it's a bad
idea to charge verified accounts for
being verified this is really stupid
[ __ ]
and that he thinks when all the verified
accounts leave because he's charging
them money it'll be good for Twitter you
are a dumb and that's how he's gonna
combat Bots but you're gonna give these
[ __ ] Republican in-cell right-wing
[ __ ] fascist control of our economy
what more proof do you need than to go
[ __ ] vote against these [ __ ]
it's enough of this stuff it's enough of
it
lean into it lean into democracy lean
into your voice
it will make a difference you don't have
to you don't have to you know I mean you
can but you you can certainly mock these
people
you can certainly make fun of them but
you can also have a conversation with
them because I guaran damned to you I
guarantee them to you your manga uncle
or your manga cousin or the Maga guy at
work absolutely doesn't understand that
they're a liberal they just don't get it
they don't know
they've been deluded like the [ __ ]
Maga assassin that went to the house of
the Pelosi's
[ __ ] deluded it's delusion it's
derangement
they're in a cult
you understand
it's a cult of misinformation
now can we count on them to to vote for
democracy no
no you can't count on them you can't
count on them
but we're gonna have to give him an
off-ramp somewhere because folks I don't
know if you noticed the early voting
numbers but it really truly does look
like
The Narrative that the Republicans are
going to win is all a bunch of [ __ ]
horse [ __ ] like I've been saying
it's a bunch of horse [ __ ]
a whole [ __ ] steamy pile of horseshit
they don't have principles they don't
have ideas
they want to take away Americans rights
they want to tell them what they can
believe and what they can't believe
the walking away of religion in this
country has nothing to do with people's
faith in God
it's because of the religious zealots
have drove them away
Americans do not do well
this country does not do well when they
are told what the [ __ ] they have to do
I don't know if you remember the
pandemic but it was damn hard to get
people to understand why it was a good
idea to wear masks in a public place
while a deadly [ __ ] disease was
spreading around amongst us and killing
hundreds of thousands of us
you think those same people are gonna
want their rights stripped away from
them no
no they're not
but you have to do something you
again
find those three people to encourage to
vote
and then get them to find three people
to encourage vote once you find those
three and you've encouraged and they've
encouraged three fine three more
I think it's up to 25 million 25 million
early votes
let me tell you something they're
they're Ballot Box their early Dropbox
intimidation isn't working
their narrative about voting machines
and voting fraud isn't working
this idea that you're not this this
narrative that you're not going to have
access to the ballot isn't working
them trying to redistrict so that they
could take over our country isn't
working
it's because of you
that's why they want to silence us
they're scared of you
of your power you have the power yeah I
can sit here and yell and scream in
front of a microphone for two hours a
day
every single day
until my voice drops
but you are the power it is you
your vote your voice your encouragement
your engagement in our democracy [ __ ]
Twitter
I wouldn't leave it yet engage there if
you can
because that message is that is a way to
spread a message far and wide amongst us
[ __ ] them
and by them I mean the fascist Charlie
Kirk literally said into a microphone
democracy is bad
not only is he trying has he convinced
his audience that we are not a democracy
he is saying the exact opposite that I'm
saying here
that democracy is bad we have drove them
to a place
us as pro-democracy people
we have drove them to a place to where
they have to oppose democracy
they'll oppose anything that we're for
absolutely anything
I believe I believe if if we came out
tomorrow and and and we supported the
overturning a row and no abortions ever
in the history of ever ever they would
now be pro-abortion
that's how [ __ ] culty they are at
this point and their cult is only
against
liberals I guess lib guards to own the
libs is their entire [ __ ] personality
and they're telling Their audience
they're saying it out loud that
democracy is bad
all the while saying we must have free
speech as if they have and and Charlie
Kirk using using and slandering the word
Liberty
they're scared folks they're terrified
they know it's a fraud
what do I mean by fraud that they have
mass support it's a [ __ ] fraud it's
it's all phony it's all [ __ ]
Elon Musk doesn't want to get rid of the
Bots he wants to create a bot Farm to
make you believe that this is the
constitutional republic it's not a
democracy they're going to be saying
that [ __ ] in your comments a lot a lot
the next week that this is not a
democracy it is a constitutional
republic they're going to say that [ __ ]
in your comments a lot and let them talk
let them yell and scream a bunch of
[ __ ] lies don't you stop yelling the
truth
[ __ ] them
I'm not gonna stop
I am not gonna quit
not gonna happen not now not ever
you can't stop me
no matter what you say or what you
tredge out or what you Docs
you will not stop me from yelling and
screaming into this microphone
and I know you're scared I know it
frightened you that the people thousands
of people come here every single day
to hear what I have to say because it
gives them cathartic release
and it enables them to go out into the
world into our democracy and engage
I show them what the fascists are doing
what they are saying what is the
direction they want to go I've been
saying for months they're Nazis
and here we are in this last week they
can't stop talking about how Kanye was
right about the Jews they can't stop
saying it they can't stop talking about
their anti-semitism
well folks you don't get much more Nazi
than that
we're there we're right there and
they're on the front door knocking like
I've been saying
and I know you've been listening
I know you have been you've you've
encouraged me to keep going you the
greatest audience in the world because
that's you are the greatest audience in
the world even the haters here even the
hate Watchers I know you're watching I
know you're listening
we're happy to have you maybe maybe
maybe just maybe your thick skull will
allow to have a decent idea
run through it just for a moment or two
why you're here listening
but do not give up do not relent
do not turn away
do not have sorrow now it's not the time
now is the time we are strong
Liberals are strong folks
that's what they're really terrified of
is liberal democracy it's the thing that
smashes up fascism
we've already seen it in Brazil in
Brazil
liberal democracy is already starting to
smash up fascism it's already starting
to prove that it's better for the
economy you think you think a bunch of
fascists are going to make the economy
good go look at what elon's doing to
Twitter right now right now as we speak
he is begging begging Stephen King in
his replies for spare change
because Stephen King is Stephen King
literally this is what is happening
and again they are some dumb
[ __ ]
but even if you have to use the
distraction to lean in use it baby use
it
why not if someone will talk to you
about Elon and you can get into a
discussion about our democracy do it
any Inlet you can use to talk to someone
about democracy now is the time it is
most important we only have one week
left
to absolutely pile them underneath
mountains of votes which I know you will
you have proven it already to me
the proof is in the pudding all this
[ __ ] media nonsense about these polls
these polls are [ __ ] garbage it is
all a bunch of right-wing propaganda to
try to convince you that Republicans are
going to win so that way when they
[ __ ] get trounced
and there's a huge [ __ ] wave of
people who are pro-democracy in this
country actually participating in it
they can say oh the polls said we were
going to win and we lost fraud there's
fraud that's what they're doing how
can't you see it they're it's always a
[ __ ] fraud to them the whole thing
start finish up and down sideways
backwards the whole thing is a fraud to
them
the whole God damn thing
but you're real
your vote is real your voice is real it
is real
and that's what they're scared of that's
what they're terrified of when Charlie
Kirk is telling his audience not only
that we are not a democracy we're not in
a micro Suite we're a constitutional
republic and a republic is not a
democracy well go look up the [ __ ]
word Charlie
but then he says democracy is bad
the right wing the Nazis are telling
Their audience that democracy is bad
we'll show them how bad it can be
[ __ ]
show them
how big can be [ __ ] show them
how awful it can be for fascism
and their bigotry and their hatred
because we will not tolerate intolerance
we will not do it
we will stand
with our brothers with our sisters as
allies in this fight for democracy
it is what we must do over the next week
and we cannot back down
we cannot shut up
and we must we must engage everybody it
is Tuesday and you know what that means
every single Tuesday is Texas Paul
Tuesday here on the Tony Michaels
podcast it's also Taco I I would imagine
last week we talked about spam with
Texas ball I would almost bet since it's
Taco Tuesday we get into some food talk
and again maybe we should just do a food
segment I don't know but I'm sure we'll
get into some food talk with Texas Paul
today Texas Paul is going to be joining
us right after the break everyone I got
to tell you again you are the best
audience in the world I am this audience
is growing by Leaps and Bounds and I
know it is because that you believe in
democracy and that you believe in the
fight for democracy and then it's worth
fighting for every single inch every
single vote every single little
conversation that you may have it is
worth all of it because democracy is not
hard it's not easy folks it is hard
democracy is harder than hell autocracy
is easy
handing over your choices to one person
and one one fascist [ __ ] is easy
as [ __ ] democracy is hard Liberals are
strong so stay together
stay together you are the best audience
in the world know that here at the Tony
Michaels podcast so join us every single
weekday on YouTube so hit the Subscribe
button right now Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific live
go follow us on Twitter still we're
still gonna be over there yelling and
screaming at Tony Michael's pod also
download every single episode and Hell
share it with your family and your
friends doesn't matter whether they use
apple Spotify Google share it with them
share it with them
and if you're on the books of face maybe
we'll go over there after Elon Tank's
Twitter just follow me at the Tony
Michaels on Facebook everyone stick
around don't go anywhere cause it's
Tuesday baby it's Tuesday and you know
what that means we got Texas Paul
joining us everyone stick around we'll
be right back right after this break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show make sure to go
visit
store.thetonymichaels.com
store.netonymichaels.com grab your
Liberty hoodie sweaters and zip up
sweatshirts today stay warm while you're
out there waiting in line voting
encouraging your friends to vote don't
forget their visit store not be Johnny
michaels.com I have Texas ball with his
Texas ball how are you
man if it got much better it might be
illegal and we couldn't do it on this
show because I tell you what
life is good brother I'm so glad you
were talking about Twitter
I have a thousand new followers since
Helen must think over Twitter have you
really yeah oh man yeah you think
they're all Elon Bots or do you think
it's something else
oh no it's something else totally it's
something else totally I tell you what
do you think it is
they never think ship through
I mean the whole time before England
took over Twitter all we heard was oh
can't wait for Twitter because they're
gonna bring Trump back and they're going
to this that and the other end oh them
liberals gonna be so tall they're going
to be we're going to be drowning in
Liberal tears
and then Elon Musk took over Twitter and
he fired the entire
portion of the company that handles
uh Banning people right
and took my filter off my [ __ ] mouth
uh Texas Gold is not working with the
filter over on Twitter breaking news
breaking news Texas ball is not working
with a filter
I love Elon Musk man I do I love that
dude I love that dude he has freed me
I can say anything I want on Twitter I
literally threatened the guy's Grandma
yesterday
I love him but well you know
Elon Elon Musk Elon Musk over the last
week has actually and I don't think
these morons know this actually I know
they don't know this that Elon Musk what
he's done by firing the CEOs all the
headers of the company
um a lot of the the data engineers and
then he he is uh locked out a lot of the
moderators out of their moderation tools
what he's actually done is killed the
profitability of Twitter like in a
matter of days he's absolutely killed
his probability of Twitter so much so
that he's begging Stephen King did you
see this he's begging Stephen King uh
for eight bucks for spare change I I I I
respectfully disagree with you you think
you think you think that Twitter's going
to be profitable after this you think oh
yeah the first time ever
you think Twitter is going to be able to
attract corporate sponsors
absolutely you think they'll be able to
attract like like all these other right
wing like parlor who are drowning in
debt true social who's drowning in debt
no because you paid you paid over 40
million dollars for a ready-made
audience you couldn't attract people to
truth social because it was a [ __ ]
boondoggle where they were trying to
charge people out the ass for [ __ ]
um yeah and it was always just one
scambot after another after another
trying to get you to give money to
Donald Trump
[ __ ]
aylin must traded in a big chunk of his
Empire for a ready-made already
functioning social platform and yeah I
think it's gonna I I do I respectfully
disagree with you I have no problem with
the new Twitter you know what here's
here's the thing here's the thing I
actually I actually don't care if
Twitter would have done this a long time
ago what what I mean by that is if if if
without Elon coming in I wouldn't have
minded if Twitter did this because if
you know what a social platform how
they're going to operate and you are
have a problem with that operation and
you stay on that platform you really
don't have a problem with the operation
right like that's the thing the people
who are not who are not cool with Elon
absolutely doing away with all
moderation are gonna stay the people who
aren't are gonna leave right so I mean I
think what you're saying is is that all
the users that are still okay with the
way the platform is going to run are
gonna be there
yeah I I 100 do I 100 do I I I I
actually not look when Elon Musk says
stupid [ __ ] right I'm all over that
[ __ ] like white on rice I am I will
tell you but I will tell you he fell ass
backwards into this and had no idea
because he thought he was going to
unleash this [ __ ] that was gonna you
know be a a billionaire suck up platform
this that and the other and it's and it
isn't it isn't it's guys like you and me
and the folks in the audience that right
that are that are there that have had to
because of the moderators handle these
little [ __ ] waffle right wing Maga
pieces of [ __ ] snowflake [ __ ]
that are melting daily
Texas Paul's Twitter feed
thank you you're almost having fun with
the trolls you're having fun oh my God
I'm having fun with the troll
over there
with the trolls
I I I'm I actually do not think that
Twitter's going anywhere right I think
it'll stay around for a long time it's
just a matter what it'll be and then who
will be there and also who owns it
because the other thing that I think
that that I highly disagree with you on
is I think and maybe maybe your your
idea comes to fruition more than mine I
actually think that it's it's not going
to be a place it's it's going to be a
place where maybe folks like you and me
to yell and scream but it's not going to
be a very good place to grift it's not
and what I mean by that is Corporate
sponsors aren't going to be able to move
in they're not going to be able they're
not going to be able to stay on the
platform without getting a lot of [ __ ]
they're not going to participate in in
Twitter and what Elon and what he tears
it down to you're gonna have verified
accounts now leaving Twitter and not
being verified if they can't be verified
which is a a lot of the reason why
people go to Twitter in the first place
I really think Elon is discounting how
much
um user base will be offloaded by the
decisions that he's making which you
know again it's a good experiment I
actually think because here's the thing
Texas Paul this hole he's going to
charge verified users I actually think
this is a good experiment what I mean by
that is that really to combat the
problem that we have with misinformation
on social media people need to certify
their social media accounts like mine
it's me it is [ __ ] me I own it it's
me with the [ __ ] I say is mine and I own
the [ __ ] I say people need to certify
their their accounts and this this
Anonymous based um
thing where what that that happens
online is where the misinformation
starts to leak through because you'll
have one person who is you know a
misinformation [ __ ] who will post on
their verified account or people look to
them and then you have mass amounts of
anonymous accounts Who start to spread
this misinformation right and not only
do they spread it they turn it around
they confuse it they conflate it there's
all kinds like this Nancy Pelosi thing
this this Maga assassin that we watched
we watched in real time exactly what
happens when when we allow Anonymous
accounts online just to say whatever the
[ __ ] it is that they want to say right
and and it bleeds into the algorithm so
I believe that this actually is one of
the best conversations that this world
can have is about social media and
frankly uh someone who who knows a lot
about but wants to have a conversation
about social media our co-host Gabe
Sanchez he's a little late Texas Paul
but he's here
um better late than never I don't know
have you heard of what we're talking
about Gabe we're talking about Elon Musk
and Twitter actually Texas ball has a
different opinion this he actually
thinks that this is going to be good for
Twitter
I do
no I do the the the whole uh you know
Twitter certified [ __ ] check mark
[ __ ] is over it's over the second you
can buy that there is no one that is
actually a verified account nobody
because you know you know it I know it
[ __ ] troll Farms are gonna buy them
I used to want to be certified on
Twitter and used to be pissed off that
there were people that nobody [ __ ]
knew I mean people walk up to me in the
goddamn grocery store Texas Paul I love
you this and the other keep saying the
[ __ ] you're saying and [ __ ]
that I know have never been hugged in
their life
had had verification tags and it used to
piss me off but it's over it's over
verification is done okay it was [ __ ]
up for a long time to begin with and now
it's done I don't mind that and if and
if Elon Musk was to grift off that for a
while let him
let let them get the troll Farms to
[ __ ] pay him I don't care I don't
care because you know why Tony it in
game
this is perfect for you and me perfect
for you and me because you can verify
anything I [ __ ] say
you know we are independent medium
[ __ ] verify what I say we are a
good source of information and that
piece of [ __ ] over on Twitter with the
[ __ ] check mark
isn't he paid 20 bucks a month to Elon
Musk to keep his [ __ ] check mark
that's what he did and and it you know
if I I'm not going to pay 20 bucks a
month for a sticker on my account I'm
going to use my mouth and I'm gonna I'm
gonna use my mouth and I'm gonna use my
credibility surely not surely you're not
going to yell and scream into a
microphone at the custom Pond that can't
be a Texas ball thing Gabe what do you
say about this verified check so here
here here let's let's get down to the
facts all right yes I agree with Texas
ball the verification process is I mean
since it's Inception in 2009 it's been
clunky and it hasn't worked right I've
known people that are uh that are
renowned and famous and only recently
got verified and had to go through this
whole hoopla [ __ ] you've got other
people who I never heard of before where
I'm like how do you only have 500
followers I you don't have any credits
anywhere I'm not sure exactly who you
are early on
so for anyone who knows no I used to
live in San Francisco my background is
in Tech I'm design engineering I have
worked within startups the last 11 12
years do you know something about social
media is what you're saying I know I
know like a little bit a little just
like a just like a tad bit so here's the
thing early on when
um I'm gonna say like children 12 2011
Twitter was trying to figure out their
revenue sources right they'd already
introduced uh advertising in they'd say
hey look if you want to uh pay us money
we'll promote your tweets and your
account will have an uh a rep for you
we'll do the whole thing
early on I think it was within like if
you paid ten thousand dollars in
advertising we could verify that you are
this entity that you claim so basically
so like like a corporation like a
Coca-Cola or something cool or whatever
you could also be an individual at that
time that could pay to advertise on the
platform if you spent enough money I'm
not saying it was necessarily a
pay-to-play type of uh
kind of but because you're paying and
because you have to verify who you are
when you pay right your your quote
unquote verified right right so you're
verified in that way and that's how that
worked with the whole like advertising
could could bypass this whole like I
need to verify I'm actually this this
person kind of stuff
now that was for normal people now
obviously since then you know they've
gotten a little bit better but the whole
thing has been really messed up now Elon
comes in and he's got all these ideas
and all the ideas that he has are
[ __ ] dumb
and the idea even before he purchased
Twitter he said the way that you
monetize Twitter is we need a WeChat
alternative China's guide what is what
is WeChat so because I think that's
important because this is again this is
where his the the the Periscope that
elon's looking through is the WeChat
right it's not surprising that the right
Wingers are trying to emulate what the
Communists in China are trying to do but
you know that's right WeChat is a is a
communication it's a messaging app at
how it started right and the way that
WeChat works now is it connects with
everything you can shop on there you can
do this you can do that it's essential
Hub right it's also monitored by the the
Chinese gov someone says they can't hear
me well can you guys hear me well yeah
your mic's a little down you might want
to turn it up a bit uh here let me
all right how is that better yeah it's a
little better turn it up just a bit just
a bit more all right what do you get 20
decibels right now yeah go to go to 25.
let's see how that works okay here we go
there we go 24 works good Okay cool so
basically how this works is uh WeChat is
this is this Central Hub right for all
things in China everything connects
through there and now
this is uh this is what Elon wants to
recreate right he wants this place
because we don't have this anywhere else
now Facebook attempted to do this right
they bought up a messaging app uh uh
WhatsApp they bought up another social
messaging app you know Instagram
essentially is what it is uh and now
um
Facebook has attempted to do that in the
past they haven't made it work they even
[ __ ] tried to make their whole
metaverse thing and that was like if you
can't take the real world seriously then
you have to go into this virtual world
and sell my digital coins and my digital
money because I can't do it in the real
world right so that was that so that's a
flop right if you look at the
demographics of what uh Facebook has
become it's older and older generation
you know naturally the younger
generation will shift away and join the
new hot thing which what is right now
Tick Tock well I mean obviously there's
Tick Tock uh some people are coming back
to Twitter
um you know Snapchat or I mean what's
the I mean Snapchat is still there
there's also you know a lot of people
like to use be real right be real became
really popular in the last few months
over the summer
um whether it has longevity as it's like
ephemeral photo sharing in the moment
app we will see I don't know but that's
where Twitter now comes in is because
like Facebook attempted to do these
things they try to do too much and they
weren't able to do it and also in all
the demographic has a harder time
adopting these newer things so if you're
trying to have crypto and wallets and
this and that in the app that is
Facebook it's going to be harder because
you don't have that younger demographic
that is a beginning to be a larger and
larger population to actually help
spread this are you are you saying that
that Texas Paul is the older demographic
are you are you saying that I mean he
nods his head I won't say it he said it
he takes his hand off to that oh boy so
now we're at right now we're in this
moment where Elon has Twitter and he
says well I need to make money right so
obviously I know I talked about this
last week on Friday and also yesterday
is the way that you're going to see
you're going to see a a bump in in
profits uh in Q4 because he's cutting
the budget he's cutting staff he's as of
yesterday he he removed every board
member so now it's only him he has begun
cutting Executives which obviously you
know that's money but what the right
doesn't realize is like oh Elon owned
these exact Executives now what you need
to remember is those people had golden
parachute packages they walked away with
funny
you mean Elon had to pay them millions
of dollars when they fired him millions
of dollars yeah tons of money so when
when when you've got people on the right
being like Oh Elon came in and he owned
them and did this like no he didn't he
he basically gave this person a
retirement package that they against
then they could go for it and say great
I'm done all I'm gonna do is I'm just
gonna do Angel Investing the rest of my
life and invest in these smaller
companies and see if they pay out like I
would in the market right so you've got
that then you've got Elon trying to
circumvent uh not paying out people's uh
stock options because he purchased in a
trigger event caused them to vest which
I talked about yesterday so he's going
to try and avoid doing that which we'll
see what happens uh there's potentially
lawsuits but he's also trying to do them
Performance Based in smaller groups so
they're not a massive layoff he's done
it at Tesla before so he'll do it again
at Twitter now Texas Paul you're not
simping for Elon Musk what you're saying
is what
absolutely I am so breaking news
breaking news Texas fall is now an Elon
simp he's going to be um
um uh advertising Deutsche coin and
Tesla's
um he's looking for an endorsement are
you trying to get Elon to get in your
replies like he is Stephen King what's
what's so what's your view on this
because
from this show that we can have two
different views no here's my take okay
um what Gabe didn't get into is the
finances of Twitter okay Twitter has
never made money
now England's carrying a vig
1.5 billion dollars a year he's got a
cough up to keep Twitter operating
if everybody leaves Twitter
we lose Twitter we do and it's a good
platform folks it is a great platform
and it's even better now because you can
be unfucking filtered on Twitter just
like you I can cuss on this program I
can speak my mind directly on Twitter
and the reason I and and you know if he
he's he's dead and and Gabe's right he's
desperately trying to figure out how to
get this profitable because in less than
12 months he must come up with 1.5
billion dollars liquid
liquid Capital that is very different
than than this paper dreams
now now what you're saying just to be
clear is it's it's the money he owes the
people who loaned him the money well he
owes that so he's got 13 billion dollars
in debt that the banks have loaned out
right right and so when you hear him say
dumb ideas like we should charge people
twenty dollars a month
to be to stay verified right now keep in
mind you're spending 240 a year you
could probably spend that same amount to
get a gym membership somewhere in your
hometown all right or or you could spend
that twenty dollars on something you
really you could [ __ ] you go out to get
drinks tonight and spend your twenty
dollars but the thing that people need
to realize is they're bright right now
we have approximately 400 000 verified
accounts on Twitter if you multiply that
by 20 per month and then 12 months you
get yourself 96 million dollars now that
is nowhere near the figure that's a lot
of money not enough not enough that is a
fraction of the 1.5 that he needs to pay
back now remember 96 million he's got 13
billion dollars in debt and he's got to
pay a million and a half every year to
pay that off and there's no there's no
way for him to to uh develop a new
Revenue stream now the other thing from
just a product development and
Engineering standpoint what he wants to
do with what's uh with with Twitter is
like I said with uh emulate WeChat just
copy WeChat
because he doesn't do anything that's
Innovative he does just things that are
the same roundabout I'm not Reinventing
the wheel in order to do what he wants
to accomplish
you're talking about totally revamping
the infrastructure of Twitter to allow
it to be a place that basically like you
have to redo your API and how you
connect through different apps to allow
other places to connect in their
security protocols like your
Integrations and stuff right exactly you
enter an area that is now uh totally and
that's assuming that nobody charges you
other companies don't charge you to
connect to their services right
but Texas Paul but so so having said
that how do you think it makes it
profitable where you get where he comes
up with that billion dollars essentially
okay first of all if Elon Musk would
just
call me when Elon Musk
Elon I love how you say Elon I love Elin
is it Elon or Elon because I'm gonna
start saying make fun of me
hey [ __ ] I have an accent too
I'm trying to pick up on the right way
to say Elin so I'm gonna say from now on
it's Elin because I like how Texas ball
says it you know I'm horrible with names
I can't even remember my own name
sometime Texas Paul so I'm gonna go with
you go ahead I'm a blue collar dude and
I have worked my my life in Blue Collar
jobs including some including sales and
I'm I don't know why I was really
[ __ ] good in sales because I tell
people straight right Elon Musk would
just tell me Paul I gotta come up with a
vig of 1.5 billion dollars I need you to
pay you want to be you want to be
certified
you want to be verified I need you to
pay me 250 bucks to come sniff your butt
and tell me who you are
I would do that I would pay him
250 bucks to actually verify me
I mean really do it have have employees
there to do the verification but then
that cuts into the figures the Gabe's
talking about sorry backwards that cuts
into the figures that Gabe's talking
about about how much you can raise off
the verification part but the
verification part won't save Twitter
but if he was direct about it I wouldn't
have a problem with it I really wouldn't
I you know and I wish people would quit
trying to leave Twitter they're trying
to cancel [ __ ] Twitter don't do that
it's a good platform
that we could argue on that we can get
our point out on and now we are
unfiltered don't [ __ ] leave Twitter
but the point is
how does he make it how does he make it
and I will tell you how he makes it GM
is Tesla's competition GM has gone hard
into the electrical vehicle Market next
year they will be releasing a badass
pickup truck
well Ford already has theirs and Chevy's
coming to the market with theirs and and
Elon Virginia is going to look
the Chevy will drag an RV and the Ford
[ __ ] lightning trying to pull the
other direction up a hill the new Chevy
electric vehicles are [ __ ] badass and
they don't want to hand Elon Musk who
owns Tesla money they want him to come
out of his pocket for that 1.5 billion
so no he's not going to get his
competitors money which was a which is a
problem for him because many of his
competitors were advertising on Twitter
that just vaporized I mean GM literally
suspended all all advertising on Twitter
but how does he get it
exactly what Gabe is saying exactly what
Gabe is saying okay
make it a hub
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to drop money into the beginning go to
your [ __ ] investors now and tell them
you're not getting paid this year sorry
but if you want this platform to keep
going that you've got your money sunk
into you're going to give me a break
you're going to waive my [ __ ]
interest for this year and you're going
to give me the ability to reinvent this
app as a hub a marketing hub for all of
these different platforms the central
portion of and it can work
it can work but he's got to start being
[ __ ] honest about this he's got to
stop sucking that right-wing dick and
making them pretend that he is actually
backing them because he's not Elon Musk
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the right wing
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about the left
wing he is
a deep sociopath he is he gives a [ __ ]
not about anybody but healing
and where his money's going
that's it yep and I mean and he can't
make it right I mean it is it is I mean
it was very evident when he made a
statement to say like you know dear
advertisers right this is what it is uh
you know I'm not here to make money but
at the same time I'm here to make money
right like that is what's going on he
doesn't want it to be this free-for-all
hellscape I mean [ __ ] he could charge
people a dollar a month minimum I mean
you've got 237 million active users
daily on Twitter which just beats almost
every other alternative truth social gab
all that [ __ ] get her all that dumb
[ __ ] out of the water those Echo
Chambers blown out of the water 237
million active users you've got you know
seven plus billion people across the
world
that's a lot of people a lot of eyes
that are on the platform
if you really want it because keep in
mind the the back and forth that he had
with Stephen King or rather just the
right responsibility yeah the begging
the haggling okay fine we'll do it for
eight but we got to make money somehow
like okay the thing that you need to to
keep in mind here is that
even if you charged
people to keep their verified status
that does not in any way defeat Bots or
trolls okay now if you were to say hey
look this platform is no longer free
you're going to lose some people
but that would be a way to to identify
okay great we know who this person is
because it's connected to this bank
account or this credit card so now we
have an actual name and not some random
name and a random collection of numbers
at the end of it that's trying to tell
you
some crazy conspiracy theory right so if
they if he really wanted to to make a
dent right and make this kind of
unilateral decision he could say all
right everyone now has 90 days to either
keep their account
or leave it and the way that we do it is
we charge you at least a dollar I'm not
saying this way to do it but I am saying
if you want to defeat trolls and
Anonymous Bots out there then you would
charge a dollar or whatever you need to
to make sure that great there's a credit
card credit card transaction and an
actual link back to someone who is real
right to an actual uh bank institution
what have you that I could then go look
up if something were to be done I hate
crime already be committed on on Twitter
somewhere to say something I now have a
way to bake great I know who the bank
account holder is I know what they're
you know their billing address is I have
all this information in the in the means
that some agency comes forward and says
hey we need info on this person
so and that's the other thing too
Twitter now doesn't really have to
answer to anyone which is kind of a
scary thing because it's one dude it's
no longer a public institution it's not
regulated on the market anymore it's
just one dude making decisions talking
to fascists and a goddamn cat turd
account okay that's all it is nowadays
I think that um because I didn't believe
that Elon would close this deal now I I
actually think he closed this deal and
he the reason why he did is because he
felt like with his his rep he had to he
didn't want to spend the money to not
close the deal that he has of July he
was still fighting to be like I'm not
going to pay for this thing right he
didn't he didn't want to close this deal
but he did now here's what I'll tell you
here's what I'll tell you is that that's
why I didn't actually think he would
ever own it because he would do anything
he could to get out of it but he but
here's the thing is I actually think I
I'm starting to agree with Texas fall
here and Gabe hear me out I actually
think that that Elon Musk buying Twitter
more than anything no matter what it
turns into if it turns into a trash Heap
or he actually makes it into a
profitable company and everyone loves it
I actually think that the conversation
about social media is a conversation
that we all need to have we need as as a
as a society not just America right not
just a state or a county or or us as a
you in the entire world needs to have
one big conversation about social media
because part of the problem that we have
right now in this country is that we
seem divided we are not I I absolutely
do not believe that we are divided in
this country I think that's all a
[ __ ] fraud and it's a fraud that is
perpetuated by a few on social media and
it is Amplified and made it to look like
we are all divided
and we're not we're not divided if you
go if you go and you actually look at
these early polling numbers they are
they are staunchly against what what all
the polls have said that the media have
reported and I know you're like what
does that have to do with social media
it has everything to do with social
media
social media is the transfer of
information that is what it is from
account to account it is the transfer of
information and we see it with this with
this weird ass Paul Pelosi attack from a
manga assassin where the right wing not
only stepped in it immediately but now
they've doubled down once they stepped
in immediately because they're
trafficking misinformation on social
media from account to account and I
believe that is the biggest conversation
that we need to have in our lifetimes
because social media is in its infancy
this thing is still a [ __ ] baby right
we do not know we truly do not know the
rights the wrongs are what is right uh
or what is going to be made of social
media going forward so I actually think
I'm starting to agree with you Paul not
not on the fact that Elon I'm not gonna
set for him but I will I will tell you
that I do think this is a great
conversation for the world to have and
maybe just inadvertently this [ __ ]
going on Twitter joking that he's gonna
buy it and all these right Wingers
goading him in to actually buying this
thing and he got tricked almost by this
this in-cell Army of buying Twitter for
this massive amount of money which he
bought it for way more than what it's
worth way [ __ ] more than what it's
worth and now he has to he has to work
his ass off to make sure that he can
make it profitable where he's going to
lose his [ __ ] ass not just not just
in Twitter but he'll lose his ass as a
CEO of Tesla and the CEO of SpaceX
because he can't prove that he actually
is who he says he is his reputation is
reliant on making Twitter survive now
he's forced himself to do that but I
think the inadvertent forcing of the
conversation about what verified
accounts are what Bots are he's put the
world in a situation where we have to
have this conversation would you agree
Texas ball
he's put himself in danger let me let me
give you let me and first of all let me
address what Gabe said then I'll come
back to you yeah because I will tell you
what Gabe said about charging on Twitter
this is my impression of Elon Musk
charging on Twitter okay you see see
you cannot charge on that platform ever
it must be free it must be free that's
like
that that that is not going to happen
what he needs to do and how he's going
to make money
is stores he needs to sell stores
he needs to turn Twitter into the new
Etsy
he needs to charge everybody and their
brother like you and me uh the right he
needs you know and Gabe can tell you
that Gabe can tell you I keep going
backwards man I hate this mirror [ __ ] uh
Gabe can tell you that he can set up
Twitter so that you cannot use any other
platform as a store on Twitter
he can do it and he can force everybody
who wants to sell something including
corporations including you know Betty
and Bows you know when you sell your
cups on Twitter go ahead but you got to
do it in my Twitter store my Twitter
store there you go you know what you
told me on Twitter go get your Rhonda
Santos can go [ __ ] himself not on
Twitter on store.net you can tag you
Tony for he can tag you for a processing
fee for each sale which is where the big
money will roll in and then he can also
charge you for a little bit of rent for
the store which is not going to amount
to much but that processing fee will be
huge capitalism capitalism is a
[ __ ] isn't it Paul and that's
and that's really that's really what
we're talking about here and I think I
think Gabe that's what you're coming
from making me say that out loud well
because I was going to sell that to you
I was going to sell that to Elin I
wasn't going to give it to him for free
we are a cap we are a campless country
we run on capitalism but Gabe I think
that's kind of your argument because
we've had private conversations about
this is that the argument is is that
this will not be in capital in the in
the guise of capitalism will not be
marketable if it's full of just a bunch
of trash like right if you're not like
and what I mean by this is you're not
going to want a GM but we use this as an
example since they've already gone GM
does not want to be shown in a thread
which with a bunch of [ __ ] a trolls
and and inward this and inward that
they're not going to be want to be stuck
with screenshots in between all that
garbage right right besides this is why
I'm saying don't leave Twitter because
man if they do turn it into a marketing
platform like Gabe is talking about
absolutely it will drown out the trolley
[ __ ] it will drown it the [ __ ] out
it will if it becomes a real marketplace
where you can go and we can talk about
[ __ ] and this that and the other and
people can also sell their [ __ ] and and
and and it will really drown out the
trolley [ __ ] it will there will
always be trolls there's trolls on every
platform right right
but I'm telling you folks it will and
that's his way you know like I say in in
the Mandalorian this is the way you know
I mean yeah and I think I think right
now like you know I've chatted with Tony
about this is like uh watching Twitter
especially being in the Bay Area and
watching Twitter and all these other
social networks you know come into the
space and die out and you know I I've I
shared one story with him yesterday
about a company and this is a typical
type of thing where there's a company
that is has valued a large sum of
millions of dollars is sold to another
larger company they take over they [ __ ]
the bed and then sometimes the original
owner says Ah you know what I'm gonna
buy this thing back for pennies on the
dollar they buy it back but the problem
though is that at that point
after that company has already [ __ ] the
bed and ruined it for what it was it's
very difficult for them to kind of
recover and reboot themselves as
whatever this is because at that point
other people come into the space offer
themselves as Alternatives and that will
allow a peak in in people to uh to join
whatever whatever that other alternative
is now what I will say is yes I agree we
should not leave Twitter what's going on
right now though is obviously very
[ __ ] up you've got a guy who is
simping to the right and telling Tom
Finn I'm gonna look into that you know
you're telling you know a capture
priority number one I'm gonna look into
that like this is the guy who is a CEO I
yesterday talked about the things that
Elon Musk is doing to [ __ ] with all the
engineering at the staff to really put
them on edge to understand who's loyal
and who's not very trump-like kind of uh
you know mentality but it is one of
those things where it's like yeah
there's only so many ways that you can
make money and make money
considerably because right now the real
only the revenue that they have or the
source of Revenue they have is through
advertising right if you've got big
people like GM who are competitors in
other spaces with him or other companies
that don't want to they they realize
right now that he has all all the
targets are on him right and you know
one of the predictions that that I made
of earlier on which is like I don't
think it'll happen in terms of him
acquiring Twitter or him buying Twitter
but the main thing and I still think is
possible and Tony brought this up a
moment ago is like
his Focus
is almost entirely on Twitter right now
you know he said every I think every I
forget every minute every hour of his
brain power for Tesla is like up to a
million dollars in value right so he he
said that the other thing is like now
that you've got your sole Focus moved
away onto Twitter you have to realize
that this is is going to shift away the
uh the perspective that that other
people like investors and shareholders
have of of Tesla or the people that are
you know are private investors of of
SpaceX when you start putting their
money at risk when you start putting
um their their their financial kind of
representation at risk to say like oh am
I gonna make money through this
investment do you have them now doubting
themselves those board members can
easily turn around and say hey look you
uh you know we we have a vote of no
confidence right because what you're
saying is is that that as much as
Twitter is now a private company is just
Elon SpaceX and Tesla are not that way
that is that is not how they're set up
and Elon cannot change that overnight
right and and really I mean and maybe
that's kind of the point here is that
when when we talk about uh Texas poll
we'll be back to join us here in just a
second but the the the the the reason
why it is so important for people to
understand who Elon is and what he's
doing is because
everyone thought that he was buying
Twitter because of Tesla and I know I
didn't buy that for one second because
Elon has a problem with his company
Tesla the main problem is is that he
can't enter the the market because he
can't get dealerships in these states
that's what he can't get he and Ours
what's that
his problem with Tessa's Tesla is they
make shitty cars well right but but he
can't he can't get dealerships so he
can't capture the market share away from
GM and Ford once they catch up to him
which they are catching up fast really
[ __ ] fast they're catching up to him
and really honestly when you look at the
the
um when you go to the car market and you
look at the just the pure design between
what Elon Musk is calling a truck and
what America considers the truck he is
way off he is way off the mark he is not
even in the same universe as the market
is and I know that he thinks it's kind
of cool to hearken back to like the
1950s when they were coming up with a
lot of stupid Design Concepts and none
of them worked by the way none of them
worked
um his his design ideas are not going to
work either it is about the
functionality of it GM and Ford have
been waiting for the functionality to
come into the market and that is what is
happening and that is why why Elon Musk
will fail at Tesla
um and and and I believe just what Gabe
said that Tesla is going to make sure to
absolutely remove him because he doesn't
he doesn't really care about the market
just like he didn't care about the
market with Twitter and really honestly
the only reason why now he's flailing to
try to create profit in Twitter is
because he has to have it to survive
because now he's overpaid for this
[ __ ] thing that he's got to make
profitable he doesn't have a choice
that's why he absolutely has to have
authoritarian Reign Over this thing to
make sure that no one's telling him what
to do so here's a just a little a little
story for you guys so when I when I
lived in SF uh I was I started a couple
different so hip Texas SF San Francisco
San Francisco sorry it's by it's by
Nature
oh my God I don't know okay all right
Sam Francisco so what I will tell you is
a little story yeah I started a company
with a few other people that was helping
the houseless and at risk it was kind of
like it was more or less like a donation
site that went directly into a fund for
someone who was working with a provider
or a shelter and they basically were
like able to help them set up what was
like by proxy you know pseudo bank
account they got funds they could use it
for their Necessities clothes toiletries
things to get them back on their feet
you actually won an award for this
company right yeah yeah I wanna I won a
Webby for the for Designing this this
website the service
now one of our investors one of our
early investors our Angels uh was Jason
kalikanis okay
he is one of the like lieutenants within
the Elon Musk group right so he's
showing up that he said he's I might
email him just kind of my own two cents
on everything that's going on we'll see
a response but
yeah Steven get him on the show we'll
talk to him yeah so Jason uh Jason is
one of those people who is on there I
mean he asked the other day he was like
oh how much would you be willing to
spend five ten fifteen dollars uh not
gonna pay a thing and it's like 80 some
odd percent of and like I don't know 1.3
million votes came in and it was like
not gonna pay a dime you know and the
closest one was five dollars and then
obviously elon's like oh interesting so
what I will say is like the connection
there is that you've got this you've got
people who have come in from Tesla's
Engineers you've got other investors
you've got a general counsel from Tesla
I think it is as well
um you got his brother in there you've
got Jason in there you've got this like
pseudo War Room team that are trying to
figure out figure out right now
it reminds me
of when you're an early startup and
you're basically like throwing [ __ ] at
the wall and you're testing a bunch of
ideas to be like all right cool we do
have validation in the market can we go
out and do this and if so then like can
we generate that to make money and
sustain ourselves but the idea is that
they're coming up with are putting them
at risk
of not actually you know coming to the
table with the banks and saying here's
the money that we owe you what will end
up happening like Texas Paul mentioned
earlier is they're going to have to go
back to those investors and and
I I don't want to spoil uh how startups
work but they they take Investments for
unless they're very profitable and they
have a very unique Market presence and
they offer something that no one else
has and everyone wants it
nine times out of ten none of those
companies make money the only way
they're able to actually stay afloat is
they might make money to pay some bills
here and there but more or less they're
raising rounds of money millions of
dollars it might be 20 million one round
then you get revalued up the next year
or the next round it might be 40 million
60 million 200 million whatever it might
be a lot of companies it's kind of like
Juiced valuation they're just yeah I
mean like when you get your house
appraised that's essentially what you're
doing you're getting an appraisal for
your company and that changes also the
value of the options the stock option
strike price that you get when you sign
your contract so if I sign early on as
employee number one it's like 60 cents a
share and now Twitter is 5420 right and
then if you guys join on later two years
three years later it's like five dollars
a share strike price so each year they
get valued up uh hopefully they increase
in value and then those investors come
in and say yeah we'll do this round
we'll do another around we'll do another
round obviously with hopes that this
company will go public and they'll make
their money back or something like on an
IPO exactly IPO or it could be a private
acquisition you know and this is an
example right now of Twitter going
private going public then going private
again and the investors because the
shareholders because the shareholders
like we're not going to pass up on 44
billion but we've never had a valuation
like that and never will get another
valuation like that in fact in fact no
one would even come with a bid that was
higher than elons right and it's also as
as the people who run Twitter they have
a financial obligation uh their
fiduciary responsibility to say we were
offered something that is well above
market price and we can't not take it
right so everything that you're going to
see happen like right now they're
basically throwing [ __ ] at the walls and
they're trying to figure out what is
going to make things work they're
literally using Twitter as a testing
tool to see like when people pay this
thing if we offer over this thing I mean
you're seeing these things happen in
real time which is interesting but also
it's showing that they're desperate they
don't have a game plan and there's only
a limited set of like plays that they
can do before they have to pay up this
next round yeah this is Paul one one
last thought on on Twitter I'm gonna go
to a break and then we're gonna come
back because I want to talk to you about
um what Greg Abbott is doing to the
military
um down in Texas you wanted to talk
about that today so so give us one last
thought on Elon and Twitter other than
to stay on make sure to stay on Twitter
but and then we'll go to a break here
okay
um what Gabe is saying is absolutely
true again good job game
um
but Twitter is in a really Prime
situation no England didn't want to buy
Twitter he didn't it was it was a run in
his mouth thing and he thought he could
just do it
quick and easy dirty and this that and
the other and then he realized he was
way [ __ ] overpaying for the company
but it'll be okay if they can keep Elin
away from it kind of like I'll be okay
if you can keep me away from a [ __ ]
Buffet this guy does not mean to be
owning Twitter
he needs to be hog-tied and his mouth
duct taped because this is the last
thing this egotistical [ __ ]
needs is Twitter
I mean he the only thing in the time a
microphone needs to be near Elon Musk is
if somebody's [ __ ] beating him with
it he does not need to be near any
platform where he can open his mouth and
Destroy his [ __ ] companies because
one of his companies is a government
goddamn contractor and he keeps saying
[ __ ] that are risking their contracts
and they keep running to England and
saying shut your [ __ ] mouth I mean
this is really a problem if they can
survive elin's mouth
they will be okay because like he said
like Gabe was saying they've got a group
of people working on this and I will
tell you something that I wasn't going
to share here and I [ __ ] hate you for
this Tony
oh we're big reveals yeah Elon musk's
big new partner is Jack Dorsey so they
are already prepared for that scenario
the game was talking about about you
know the original owner coming back and
this that and the other his new partner
is Jack Dorsey Jack Dorsey was working
on a platform that was different than
Twitter and what it is is they're going
to merge it together and they're going
to make the Twitter Marketplace
that's what they're going to do and you
know and and Jack Dorsey has already
already put put the engineering team
together he's already got the code
written he's already and you know
England must [ __ ] the bed when he bought
it and came running back to Jack Dorsey
and Jack Dorsey said
got you man I got you
this ball we're gonna go to a break but
everyone get Get Your Meme machine going
the return of the Dorsey the return of
the Dorsey on your Star Wars memes you
get a you gotta do that up uh text ball
art can you stay with us I want to talk
about this yeah okay everyone stick
around we're gonna go to a quick break
we will be right back right after these
messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign podcast
welcome welcome back to the show we
still have Texas follow this he wanted
to talk about the Texas border and what
Greg Abbott's doing and how it is
affecting the military so I wanted to
give him a chance here to talk about it
before we go to the [ __ ] list Roundup so
Paul we got about maybe 10 minutes or so
and then we got to do the shitless
Roundup because I got some videos I want
these folks to see on Texas Paul so what
what's going on down there in Texas tell
us what Greg Abbott's doing [ __ ] [ __ ]
waffle Greg Abbott
I swear to God okay look
he is just
military recruiting's in the [ __ ]
okay it is it's just in the [ __ ]
period before we even start this
conversation know that the military and
Congress are freaking the [ __ ] out they
cannot get enough people to go in the
military because people do not want to
be used as a [ __ ] prop and they don't
want to be used as somebody's goddamn go
get me some land so I can take some oil
[ __ ] god they don't they people
signed up for the Texas National Guard
let me go to the Texas make this taxes
now they signed up for the Texas
National Guard these are people that
have lives jobs doctors dentists you
know everybody in the officer's Court
you're talking about you know work at
these are educated people working
high-end jobs everybody that's in that
that's in the enlisted core are are your
labor they are your people that are out
there that have lives and they don't
have time
to go out and spend a year at the
[ __ ] border to be used as a goddamn
recruitment tools [ __ ]
[ __ ] goddamn habit running for
office commercial they don't have time
for that in their lives what is he doing
what do you mean so you're saying it's
political theater what they're doing at
the border that he's using the Texas
National Guard how is he doing that I
mean because my my take on it is he's
spending money that should be going to
Texans and he's spending it on this like
you said they're props down there
for 25 years Republicans have been in
control of Texas and they have used the
justice system here as a weapon they
have they have weaponized our justice
system and he took 360 billion dollars
out of
our jail system which has a 2.5 billion
dollar annual budget and is underfunded
because they use it as this [ __ ]
racist [ __ ] attack program to lock
people up throw people in jail and make
money for private jails he took
you know a third of a billion dollars
out of this program that was underfunded
to begin with and already has human
rights abuses going on in it to pay for
the Texas guard at the Texas border
which isn't doing a [ __ ] thing we've
had almost we've eight Guardsmen have
unalived themselves down there because
their [ __ ] lives were destroyed by
this [ __ ] [ __ ] then he takes
people that are here legally that are
part of the the the legal process of
becoming an American
bullshits them scams them steps them on
a [ __ ] bus treats them like [ __ ]
won't even let them stop and take a piss
to be a goddamn prop and no people don't
want to be part of that they don't want
to be part of that so we can't get
people signed to sign up for the guard
we can't get people to sign up for the
military we can't get and and and the
guard's doing [ __ ] nothing down there
in the desert
nothing literally just [ __ ] driving
around well what is their assignment I
mean what is their assignment is their
assignment they have no assignment they
have no assignment no Mission they are
there to be a prop so that Abbott can
send his campaign people down there and
take pictures next to helicopters and
Humvees that that's their [ __ ]
assignment down there so basically the
idea is to use Texas uh the money that
would otherwise go to helping Texas
prisons right
um it is is to so they can take pictures
with helicopters and military trucks and
military personnel standing there it's
kind of what yeah and and uh guys it's
[ __ ] destroying our military it is
destroying our military they are
literally falling so short of their
recruitment
goals that that Congress is in a full
freakout mode because they're like oh
[ __ ] we can't we can't really
significantly raise their pay how do we
make this more attractive and you can't
because all over
people who signed up to do a job a real
job to defend our country to be there in
a crisis situation whole you know
good-hearted people signed up to do very
important things
are not going to be [ __ ] on this way did
you hear what they did with their
[ __ ] taxes go ahead they didn't even
they did oh my God they just
the way they set up the pay in the Texas
National Guard these people are being
[ __ ] in their taxes they they are just
literally getting tax bills they never
knew were going to be there that are 80
higher than what they thought their
taxes were going to be because they
don't do any [ __ ] withholding this
was the last minute operation Lone Star
[ __ ] hate that they used the word
lone star that is sacrosanct in the
[ __ ] state of Texas and this [ __ ]
weak piece of [ __ ] who was knew he was
going to get his ass kicked in this
election is using them
using the [ __ ] guard as a [ __ ]
prop and pretending they're doing
something down there and and you know
you know why it's so [ __ ] bad too is
it's like they're they're taking they're
making arrests in Dallas
you know [ __ ] Chad up in Dallas who
for ordered [ __ ] fentanyl components
from [ __ ] China and is making
Fentanyl and [ __ ] Dallas and they're
claiming that it's a border arrest
they're claiming it's been a lower
cartel
well well here's what I'll tell you is
this Pro cartel well here's
here's what I'll tell you Texas Paul
Republicans destroy everything like you
destroyed buffets Apparently that is
that is what the lesson is for today
Texas Paul I always appreciate having
you on
um I I love that you do not stop yelling
and screaming I love that you don't stop
talking I actually appreciate your take
on Twitter this morning
um I think a lot of other people will
start to think about this start having
conversations about it because you
shouldn't leave Twitter at this point
Gabe you got those links I sent you pull
up Greg been a beast here in the [ __ ]
chat let me tell you something you
little [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you want
me to prove it I brought [ __ ]
receipts you little [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] receipts with me you little
piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] come talk to me
I'll [ __ ] shove my hand so far up
your [ __ ] ass that your mother will
cry for [ __ ] decades you little piece
of [ __ ]
I've never known a high road in my
[ __ ] life
um I will [ __ ] low road Mad Max your
ass out of [ __ ] existence
[Laughter]
you want to feel my hands fill my
[ __ ] hands
pull this comment up so that makes
[ __ ] sense this one
or is there another one he says
yeah hold on I'll try to find it
um here is um here is uh there you go
you [ __ ] [ __ ] this one was it was it
this one you read this is this is from
armytimes.com uh Texas pools from the
state prison budget for operation Lone
Star funding uh this reporting is by
Karen Brooks Harper of the Texas Tribune
uh Thursday October 27th
um so this is this is a pretty recent
um oh no oh no uh no
um this is uh Gabe fake Gabe this is uh
this is the uh Republican governor of
Texas not because we don't have a
democratic Center yet does fake Gabe
think that Texas is currently run by a
Democrat he's a dumb [ __ ] so he may
believe that but so far if you read here
so far more than 4 billion has been
spent to keep thousands of Department of
Public Safety Troopers and Texas
National Guard members stationed along
the Texas Mexico border
um these are facts I don't know if you
if just because they don't align with
what you want to believe and your little
fascist little uh wet dream that you
have about the Border but it is Texas's
money that is causing the National Guard
which you see here in the picture these
are not these are not active duty
military this is Texas National Guard
which the Republican Governor Greg
Abbott has the authority over and he's
using the budget to siphon money off of
Prisons to send it to make sure that
these National Guardsmen are I don't
know standing here while he has his
photo up I don't I don't know what you
don't get fake Gabe I don't know why you
continue to challenge the challenge
facts but you really should you really
should get a life you really should get
a life I mean we love it I mean here we
love that you listen but you really
should get along I mean it's like that
one time fake Gabe tried to tell us that
illegals were voting in the election and
then sent us a link to the New York vote
right that was shot down
he doesn't think things through he just
regurgitates lies I don't know how he
thinks that having a state with two
Republican Senators other Republican
representatives and a republican
governor governor lieutenant governor
attorney general the rest of them
Republican Paxton is the one that's
literally been indicted federally
indicted for his crimes is he a Democrat
is he a Democrat oh no he's a republican
he's also I believe uh him Ted Cruz and
others were also part of the group that
decided to say oh it should be one door
in and one door out right that's those
Republican policies those are the
Republican Representatives
I don't know anywhere in the state that
we're getting Democrats that are
actually able to make the decisions
right now it's literally run fake games
fake game fake Gabe I don't know know
anything about Texas but it's run by
Republicans
go ahead and I have to say I used to
take medicine for that
and I don't anymore
I'm just warning you little [ __ ]
the Texas call is
to take from hurting people like you I
don't take it anymore he's caffeinated
and unmedicated here on the Tony
Michaels podcast Texas Paul thanks for
joining us tell us one more time where
we can find your Independent Media
because you've been doing such a great
job uh everyone go follow it you've got
the channel but tell us where we go
my brother from another mother uh
Tennessee Brandon my Buddhist friend
he's my balance he is he he is my
balance
um my brother from another mother
Tennessee Brando and I got a show coming
on tonight right after the the mighty
shows podcast we will pop in right on
their coattails because you know that's
smart to do
[Laughter]
so catch us tonight for TNT Brando it
will literally pop off as soon as uh as
soon as the guys are done
8 30 Central about right there just make
sure you go over to Texas Paul Channel
as soon as the Midas touch podcast is
over and done Texas Paul thanks for
joining us as always everyone stick
around we will be right back okay hold
on day Paddock Dave Paddock see me
[ __ ] see me
please see me [ __ ]
let's let's
test your theory at your earliest
convenience [ __ ] please
try me we'll be right back right after
these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slim Jims skull
near run out Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow
so we can Circle the city again here's
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
here's Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
you goddamn right we're back
[Music]
God damn right we're back
got 30 more minutes we're at the bottom
of the second hour we're gonna get to
the [ __ ] list
holy [ __ ] Texas ball on fire today as
usual he's always hot here on the Tony
Michaels podcast
he was in he was in hot like that but uh
that was
better way better watch yeah Dave better
watch out yeah fill your hand you son of
a [ __ ] do you know what movie that's
from you know movie that's from fill
your hand you son of a [ __ ] no that's
from uh True Grit
um yeah so when uh when they're gonna go
into a gun fight and right right that's
with uh Jeff Bridges right well that
that is the Remake the original
um it's a book it's a book and the
original was John you read
hey [ __ ] you buddy
I didn't actually read the book no
actually actually the the the movie
um that Bridges did
is much more like the book than the one
that they made with John Wayne the one
they made with John Wayne is a John
Wayne movie right like right they took
this book and like okay how do we make
this into a John Wayne movie because all
the John Wayne movies are like pretty
much kind of they're kind of the same
yeah yeah so that's the original and
then
um the the Remake though is a little
closer to the actual
um the actual book that was written but
but the the there's one part at the end
where
um the hero the John Wayne or the jet
Bridges is going to be Mark uh Galloping
towards and and a shootout and he says
fill your hand you son of a [ __ ] it
just reminded me of Texas ball slang man
so do you feel lucky do you do you do
you punk hey I want to point something
out game everyone's been really confused
see this uh this Banner here that says
lock him up uh you see that there that
Banner there is on our merch store
store.thetonymichaels.com I hung it up
here because I think it's a really great
Banner I'll lock him up with the red tie
you can't really tell who I want to have
lock him up can you but lock him up
Banner is over on store.dj michaels.com
but people are really confused because I
used to have my McNuggets right chicken
mcnugs you know I love my chicken
McNuggets next sign used to hang right
here behind me and some people were
questioning where it is and they're not
paying enough attention because it's
right here see that right there it's
right there yeah I still love chicky
mcnugs right so my my nugs not drug sign
is right there for all anyone who is
okay so just one from the one from the
left to the right from over here I moved
it to put the banner here because the
banner didn't fit very well here maybe
I'll try backwards yeah yeah well don't
don't excuse people too much well just
to see if they catch on right
lock him up here these trolls are really
confused about what happens here because
they really they don't really pay
attention much they're dumb [ __ ] well
they probably have never redecorated or
moved things around in a room you know
and maybe maybe I'll move the lock him
up again somewhere else when we get
maybe another Banner or something else
that I want to go here because these are
like these are my walls that I got here
so I can move my [ __ ] around but I just
want to let everyone know that the nugs
not drug sign is still loud and proud
for the chicky mcnugs because I still
love the chicky mcnugs as everyone knows
but here's the thing I got a few videos
I want to show you okay there's a few
videos so let's do this let's go to the
shitless Roundup let's round up all the
Tweety tweets and trendy Trends wise
Twitter is still operable everyone let's
start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome welcome
I don't know what's going on my new
yourself my dude what are you are you
censoring yourself I think so I think it
might be that that um we're gonna start
to talk about Twitter so elon's
controlling me but now I have no idea
um there's a few videos I want to show
you here the first off is Adam kinzinger
this morning I think he puts it so well
I'm not always a fan of Adam kinzinger
but when he's talking about well you'll
see what I mean yeah yeah when he's
talking about what he's talking about
here I I enjoy it make sure the volume
level is okay yeah it's [ __ ] down and
it did let's get the volume level up
here so everyone can see we may have to
change our volume so they can turn it up
or down but let's let's listen here
when Elon deleted his tweet which was an
insane tweet you know everybody's like
oh you're back you're acquiescing to the
left-wing mob I want to make it clear
too by the way Liz and I are not are not
courageous there's no strength in this
we're just surrounded by cowards and
then complete contrast to cowardism it
looks like courage when it's just your
bear Duty
amazing pretty crazy when you're like
hey you're this thing and it's like I'm
just doing my job right I'm just calling
it out right I'm just saying what you
should say right in any normal timeline
like right normal timeline I'm just
saying what you should say right it's
not it's not it's not crazy right it's
just like some you know having certain
rights and things aren't radical and
this is this is what we've said this
whole time about Adam kinzinger and Liz
Cheney like they're not our allies yeah
yeah they really aren't our allies they
were a tool they helped us right they're
a bulldozer but the only tool is is that
what Anne mckinsisker is willing to say
is that hey I'm not being courageous I'm
just doing the bare minimum and because
I'm surrounded by a bunch of [ __ ]
cowards in my party it makes me look
courageous I'm not I'm just saying what
they the decent bare minimum thing and
and he's referring to the tweet that
Elon deleted about the article we talked
about it yesterday where he tweeted out
that misinformation about the Paul
Pelosi attack the manga assassin
um that that attempted to kill him and
then I gotta say in in the last couple
years there's definitely been a lot of
like Maga
themed
uh assailants right these people who are
the shooters and and uh uh attackers and
all of these people they they seem to
it's crazy it's almost like there's like
a
An Origin point that you could like link
back to and be like huh all of these
things that you're screaming about and
admitting to and saying that this is
what you believe it seems all come back
from could there be huh well let's hear
what Tucker Carlson may have to say
about some of this speech that has been
uh disseminated by people let's listen
what is hate speech by the way all of a
sudden everyone in the media has sort of
without explaining why agreed that
there's this thing called hate speech
that's real and probably actionable
they can find a billion dollar judgment
against you if you commit hate speech
but just to remind everyone watching
there's no such thing as hate speech
okay I think what he's referring to here
Gabe is the Alex Jones trial his buddy
it's definitely a wink a wink wink to
that right what's going on because he
talks about a billion dollars and and to
be clear what Alex Jones was
participating in because I know that
Tucker Carlson wants what Alex Jones was
doing is hate speech what he did is
defamation and libel that's what Alex
Jones did he spread lies about people
that caused them actual damage yep
actual money damage and he continued to
do it after they asked him to stop and
he continued and continued he still
continues to this day to do this garbage
where he demonizes the parents of little
children at Sandy Hook which is really
[ __ ] gross when people do anything
right anything to actually [ __ ] joke
or make a funny joke about the Sandy
Hook shooting it's really [ __ ] gross
it's real it was little bitty children
that were [ __ ] ripped apart by I
would hope that people like regardless
of whatever your take is on guns right I
would hope I would hope that your stance
anywhere along the line would say yeah
making fun of Vivaldi Sandy Hook like
any of these shootings that they might
happen especially for little children
that you go yeah there's a line and uh
doing anything to make light of it or
make fun of it or spread misinformation
is just gross wrong it's [ __ ] gross
now here you can joke about the shooting
but your aim needs to be directed at I
don't know the shooter or maybe the gun
manufacturers or maybe the people who
allowed the [ __ ] psychopath to get
the gun because jokes and comedy have
aim right and what Tucker Carlson is
doing here is not using comedy he's
actually using his fascist microphone to
actually target the people who of Sandy
Hook the parents of Sandy Hook to say
that that hate speech doesn't exist and
that they don't deserve the defamation
in a libel suit that they were rewarded
by the court by the jury
because it it's hate speech and hate
speech doesn't exist which is really
honestly I mean it's kind of
mind-bending in the first place because
again
this lawsuit that it seems like Tucker
is referring to the billion dollars that
they can sue you for for hate speech it
was defamation and libel against
that he committed against the parents of
Sandy Hook because he kept doing it
knowing he was doing it that's how they
gave him the thing but really honestly
do you do you notice how Tucker Carlson
is trying to make the word the the hate
speech not about people of color like
he's ripping it away from because right
now the court is trying to decide on
affirmative action but he's they they
these white supremacists are trying to
rip more and more and more of Truth away
from people of color and and the fact
that he is yelling and screaming to
white supremacist microphone and a bunch
of white supremacists saying hey there's
no such thing as hate speech go out and
do it what are they going to do sue you
I mean it's the same thing that we've
seen from you know Kanye West this
embolden Embrace of one person saying uh
oh hey we should attack these Jewish
people and be anti-semitic you've got
this guy who broadcasts to millions of
people and uses platform to question
what is racism
what is uh White Privilege does it
really exist I'm just asking questions
inquiring minds want to know no it's not
it's you using that as a tool as a
delivery mechanism to say
well is it bad is it by asking the
question you're you're casting doubt on
something that everyone knows is
or most sane people know are true right
yes there is racism yes there is White
Privilege yes there are these things
right he comes in here and he's like oh
is such a thing as H yeah literally
defined by the [ __ ] doj it's a crime
to say or do certain things against a
certain group of people that you're
targeting it's literally a hate crime
just like it was a hate crime for that
one guy who drove his car into a crowd
of people in Charlottesville right like
these are things that are verifiably
true there is no doubt and if you do
cast doubt then you have to ask yourself
what is your argument what is your
position because I'm sure Jeremy Johnson
and fake Gabe and that other [ __ ]
Dave dude are gonna argue
the same position that Tucker Carlson
has or that Trump has or any of these
others I'm going to show you Charlie
Charlie
these people they're going to just bring
them up and hold them to say yeah there
isn't racism or there there isn't hate
speech that's not a real thing
I would I would assume that you you
would agree that hey we shouldn't attack
certain people we shouldn't be violent
against certain people based on their
religious background their racial
background whatever it might be you
would think that those people
who are in the comments simping like
yesterday fake Gabe right simping
say persecuting the conservatives when
we're literally only mentioning Nazis a
guy dressing up as a Nazi this is the
Republican party right this we have one
week seven days right that's all seven
days until we can we can finally try to
put a nail in this coffin that is how do
you say this this handle here on is it
Pilates I think that's how you say
Pilates I hope I got it right you you
you commented they want attention bloody
they are getting attention that's the
problem that's what we try to do here is
show you who are the ones who are
getting the attention that are
disseminating this misinformation that
are that are bleeding the minds of
people like fake Gabe Dave Jeremy in the
chat
Jeremy Dave and fake Gabe in the chat
are copying they're carbon copying these
people is what they're doing so it
doesn't matter if we give them the
attention what we're trying to do is
show you where these people are getting
this garbage from where they're getting
it why they're in the comments why
they're saying the [ __ ] that they're
saying because sunlight is the best
disinfectant and that is what we need on
these people is a big huge [ __ ]
Spotlight on these son of a [ __ ] and
here is here's another big huge
Spotlight Gabe uh I I mentioned it in
the first a block of the show and why it
is so important that you must go vote
because they are suppressing their own
vote
I don't think Dave realized it yet um
they they have they have so far
convinced the media that these
right-wing polls that they're doing are
correct yeah and it's not proving out in
the the early voting numbers none of it
none of that [ __ ] that garbage pulls
that the media has been reporting on is
playing out even in the aggregate it
just [ __ ] up the aggregate even like
the aggregate numbers are being [ __ ]
up because they're they're just doing a
full-on trudge of right-wing polls right
but here's the deal the reason why is
because they want to so doubt that we
even have a democracy and that democracy
is good listen to this dumb [ __ ] on his
show you see the Electoral College is a
republican idea not a Republican party
idea but a small R Republic idea the
American Founders were extremely wise
the Constitution spreads power across
branches of government
but it also spreads over geography and
time this is what makes a republic
different than a democracy
okay Charlie Kirk is right that a that
the the the
presidential election that we have the
one election the one vote that we take
in this country
that the Electoral College is a a
constitutional republic idea what he is
failing to recognize is all the all the
other all the other [ __ ] elections
that you're gonna go vote for in one
week have nothing to do with the
Electoral College not a goddamn thing
not a [ __ ] thing the electoral
college has no effect on any election in
this cycle not one of them not [ __ ]
one and that is the lie he's fake Gabe
you see what they do to you they they
rope you in with one little crumb of
Truth where he says one election every
four years we use the Electoral College
whether you like it or not that is how
it's that's how Donald Trump actually
won on a technicality do the actual
constitutional republic idea of
electoral college in a presidential
election they use that little Marshall
to get your attention like oh it's true
it must be true then wait to what he
says wait watch what he says now Gabe
I have been on the record and I'll say
it again democracy is a bad idea
that's how they get you fake Gabe that's
how they get you that's how they rope
you in that's how they tied to one
[ __ ] morsel which the truth is folks
the truth is is that Charlie Kirk is a
dumb [ __ ] but he knows exactly
what he's doing he knows exactly what
he's doing he is taking that little
crumb that little morsel about a
constitutional republic and democracy
which a constitutional republic is a
[ __ ] democracy our constitutional
republic is a democracy just wait until
next week when they're yelling and
screaming about Vape votes and fake
votes and votes votes and votes this and
votes that that's all democracy folks
that is democracy I mean they've already
said it they're going to uh you know
they're gonna try they're gonna do a
trial run of this in Pennsylvania right
wow you're right they're right they're
they've already got they already got
lawyers on the ground ready to see
because they know they're going to lose
right and it's it's and even more even
more reason I mean they're going to it
no matter what they're going to
challenge it they're going to cast out
though we know that not only
was it proven to be debunked and false
because the the Republicans like Rudy
Giuliana and Jen Ellis and Donald Trump
and all these other people didn't
actually have facts or a case they had
theories right they were like well we
didn't have any actual evidence we had
theories that's why they got literally
laughed out of the courtrooms especially
when there was those uh Trump appointed
judges which was just [ __ ] even more
beautiful of a moment
even more beautiful when you had a you
know former Attorney General Bill Barr
saying it's [ __ ] bull [ __ ] all these
claims of widespread voter fraud
[ __ ] we find that in the Villages
the highest concentration of voter fraud
happened from [ __ ] Republican
retirees
so voting voting vote double voting for
Trump right not for democrats for Trump
we've had Republicans in the last
election who tried to say well you
should vote by mail if you get it and
then you should also vote again in
person that's literally voter fraud you
that you're you're illegally voting
twice you're gonna get kicked out and
they're going to identify that it was a
second ballot and also it's one vote so
you're not having something on a scale
of millions right Millions is what
you're trying to argue here is that
you're getting you're getting defrauded
by over seven to eight million votes and
that's why Trump lost the last I wish I
wish I had enough time that I could show
the clip on 60 Minutes of the Arizona
the current Arizona Secretary of State
um saying that that it's all [ __ ]
the only fraud that they found in the
entire State of Arizona was four four
[ __ ] ballots four [ __ ] ballots and
it was in the primary not the general
right it was in the primary not the
general election he's the one who wants
to be part of the deciding party or
right power to say oh well if it's not
how I want then I'm going to toss it out
even though it's four votes in the
primary speaking of Arizona
um we've had this this character on here
uh Melanie Jennings she is I don't know
if she's a spokesperson the leader I'm
not sure what she is uh clean elections
Q Anon USA excuse me not Q Anon I I keep
adding that in because everything they
say and everything they do really
borders upon this Q Anon crap
um so we played a video yesterday where
they kind of backtracked after they have
full on
using intimidation tactics at these drop
boxes and the federal judge said hey I'm
not gonna punish you for doing the thing
that's legal which is standing far
enough back and observing The Ballot or
The the ballot Dropbox which we have
said over and over and over again people
there's no reason to go observe the most
secure ballot Dropbox that there is in
Arizona you sh if you're going to
observe really honestly if you're going
to observe you should be observing other
boxes that are not as secure as the one
that they're they say that they're
observing but also good luck good luck
standing outside of the [ __ ] post
office with guns right and see what
happens when you start [ __ ] around
with something like I don't know Federal
buildings yeah well here's the thing so
Melanie here Melody Melanie whatever her
[ __ ] name is Miss Jennings here
um looks like I I almost look like this
is a freeze frame yes from some
paranormal movie that we're watching
it's really weird it feels like she has
a green screen on but she does have a
green screen is that what it is yeah
it's like it looks like a showroom like
it's like a Furniture showroom in the
background
you expect these fraudsters not to have
the fraud background but here's what I
want to say here's what I want to say is
that yesterday we played a video where
this lady uh Miss Jennings and her
organization is having to comply with
the judge saying hey you cannot
intimidate people and if I catch you
intimidating people I'm gonna shut you
down so you're gonna have to make sure
and she even said yesterday they were
going to hold up signs thanks for voting
oh yeah which was not what their intent
was before we know that when you show up
with [ __ ] mask on your face tactical
gear and weapons your your idea of
thanks for running is not that idea
listen how she's changed her tomb even
from yesterday because it feels like to
me Gabe that they're gonna have a court
battle on their hands and they're using
Steve bannon's Trader TV to start that
Court battle listen actually completely
still sitting quiet those two people we
found out were a hundred feet back just
sitting between their cars minding their
own business and it was the news and uh
some people that we've found out on
Twitter who discovered them and said
let's make this crazy and so we actually
have the footage of this person and I
won't give all the sauce that we have
right now from their their personal
camera uh the footage that they took and
it literally tells a different story we
have the picture of that person who came
up to them laughing it up with the news
we have a picture of it
um and then we also have footage of you
know
the news staging a whole situation on on
this last Saturday evening which we
haven't broken yet and we will but this
is going to go in our Direction because
you know honestly if anyone's doing the
intimidating it's them and the news is
in I you know I don't I'm going to say
allegedly the news is in on it
okay so there you have it Gabe this
person is claiming that the news is
doing the intimidation she she
specifically threw in there allegedly
because she knows right what will happen
if she goes the media is conspiring with
these people to draw a False Image or
impression of what we're doing we're
just there as Patriots supporting our
election with guns body cameras tactical
gear and face masks right
and so she's like oh allegedly allegedly
well here's what I'll tell you is that
folks the media it's actually
um their job it's their job to make sure
that they ask the appropriate questions
at the appropriate times to hold people
accountable and when the media comes up
to you when you're doing something when
that when it's an actual person of the
press who holds press credentials they
have the right to ask you questions they
have the right to hold clean elections Q
Anon USA accountable rather Miss
Jennings likes it or not and my guess is
that the media is digging and my guess
is that there are people out there that
are digging for the proof that these
people are using intimidation tactics
and what she's talking about
um it seems like she's threatening to
dox the person who actually went up and
and actually well yeah because she's
like oh we'll break more on that story
later there's literally nothing more to
break there's nothing more to break here
it's that you uh your people were there
intimidating and the media showed up
after it had all gone down they were
under the big plan of course we're the
victims oh my God feels so bad for us we
didn't do this this and that
again guys it's projection it's victim
blaming you know they're trying to play
the victim and they're trying to say
they're the bully they are the assailant
they're the ones who are targeting us
we're just representing our
constitutional rights to guard these
ballot boxes with weapons
and tactical gear they really are a
bunch of whiny little [ __ ] aren't
they I mean little [ __ ] the other
thing is if our ballot boxes really did
need that type of
security
we would have people
that we paid
by the government to do that you know
what's funny you know what's funny is
even in that situation of the video
where the lady goes and she approaches
these people in a way that is
non-threatening she just sits there with
her camera and the guy's holding his
camera in front of her face and [ __ ]
and literally literally people who are
armed armed individuals who are hired by
the government come to help protect that
situation now rather you agree with the
the law enforcement or not the way they
handle it which was kind of ridiculous
how they handled it they're really
trying to get these people to disperse
which again they don't have much
Authority if you're standing so far back
from the box right they really don't you
have the right to film you had to like
to observe I mean it's on public
property you know like there's one tent
your intent and motive are important
right and that's what the judge was
telling this lady in this in the private
hearing that's why yesterday you order
on our show on Steve bannon's Trader TV
News Network saying oh we're gonna hold
up signs that say thanks for voting
because again they're trying to do
everything they can to intimidate you
even if the judge orders them to look
like they're not doing that they're
gonna try to do it but Gabe here's the
news they're not intimidating anyone I
bet I bet right now if they ran the
numbers we're almost over 25 million
early votes 25 million early votes and
the majority of those early votes of
course are Democrats because these
people don't even believe that early
voting is is legal in some states well
they're not going to they're not going
to do it because they're going to say oh
that's illegal my brain my vote wouldn't
be counted right all this [ __ ] well
because they don't want they don't want
early votes counted so why would they
are the they're literally suppressing
their own vote right now and folks my
suggestion to you as it is every single
time we talk here on this show is to
encourage three people three people to
go and lean into democracy and go vote
and then have them find three people and
once you find those three people and
you've encouraged them find three more
it is super important we're down to the
we're down to the wire here Gabe it is a
week away from the most important poll
that is going to happen in our
democracy's lifetime and then is
election day for the midterm and you
must make this poll count don't believe
all the other polls out there because
they're all [ __ ] they're proving to
be [ __ ] with these early voting
numbers
20 25 million and we're only we're we
got a whole week to pile more votes on
top of these people folks do your duty
lean into democracy engage in your
democracy you can do it by watching
every single weekday right here on the
Tony Michaels podcast noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch don't forget to subscribe while
you're here on YouTube and don't forget
to download every single episode on
Apple Spotify Google leave us a great
review while you're there and if Twitter
goes to [ __ ] come on over to Facebook I
don't know if Twitter goes to [ __ ] you
can come follow us at Tony Michaelson on
Facebook
oh boy what a timeline we're living in
Gabe Sanchez what a time to be alive
whoosh it is something else tomorrow
same time same exact exact place Surf's
Up [ __ ] you've been listening
to the Tony Michaels podcast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] em
foreign
[Music]